hello and welcome to this video
yeah I recently won against this guy
it's it's justice oh yeah I remember
yeah it was a BOGO with black and it
worked out really nicely so why not do
it again let's see if we have any
improvement in store I place the same
substandard line okay again it's not
like that black is better after night
pd-2 let's see what happens I just play
the same way there's really no way - no
reason to deviate what I learned from
the analysis is that after castles
efore I'm not actually better which I
thought would be the case but we'll see
what happens
I was so going for if he castles why not
well it doesn't seem that he looked at
this in any way after he was getting
clobbered last time
let's see castles cannot be bad yeah
it's interesting to see what to do I
can't even even see five is an
interesting move in this position
because the Nile is just so bad on the
tomb it's probably not necessary but I
always had a soft spot for playing c5
and 96 in such a position so that the
night is not obstructing the c-pawn the
easiest for me would be if he goes d5
that is just like ya and I ever that's
an interesting choice him so he
acknowledges that the night is just bad
on the two that's definitely true so
yeah ship chief form E for 96 all those
moves look quite logical
let's do this it cannot be bad and I'm
threatening you form even though h3 is
interesting it's an interesting it's
interesting to consider what what I
should do then
any more or less has to play age three I
mean what else is down okay Bishop age
five he will play g-force it's clear I
was actually thinking that taking and
putting the knight on to c6 could be an
option just putting more pressure on the
D pawn yeah but it would probably take
play Knight c3 hmm it's not entirely
clear to me Bishop
h5 g for I don't know a queen to F Queen
takes F 3 s is probably not right I know
I don't understand the move I thought I
just get control over d4 now I mean it's
not the end of the world for white but I
thought Bishop takes it's just whoops
oops and then that happens if you think
the opponent just plays badly strategic
game where you you forget one movers can
just take this okay
I wasn't really thinking about anyone
movers versus thinking okay this guy's
playing very weird stuff strategically
speaking and didn't really consider that
b7 was hanging which was the simple idea
okay
and I had just 96 of course that was a
very decent alternative even though then
he can take him play 93
yeah maybe Kunia three was quite okay
then it looked really odd to me but okay
when this is not this position is not
terrible I've got a really good
development and this is the key thing
here making it difficult for white to
coordinate the night mmm yeah that's I
should do this I think immediately
attacking the pawn and I'm thready
creamy to us this is a big threat so
there is only night a three queen bee to
night b5 yeah he has to play that it's
just like the only move I have Knight b6
in this position I don't know if I take
it yeah I think taking should be correct
would be weird if that that isn't
correct
so mmm okay
a six there's rook to be won a six-night
X will be eight wins apiece so that is
not really a thing rupee one Nestor is
the thing okay I need added some lift
for the king
tough to do this to play without this
move
okay Knight b6 and take take one c4
maybe that looks correct and they have
to speed up definitely maybe five was a
thing I don't know okay I have to see
that I'm not falling asleep here yeah
let's cover c4
so I'm a pawn up and I got a little bit
of an initiative going the Queen Queen
on b2
where were you going in 97 maybe mmmm he
looks kind of normal
checking f2e he has to take it basically
okay I really thought he had to take it
even even taking one f29 f2 is still an
idea 9f2 king takes 23 is made so hmm
that's annoying he didn't see this move
but still it's kind of playable for him
I might have to
95 224 just keep keep discovered my twin
stuff okay yeah there was a bit of a bit
of a weird game really so yeah I think
this is failed or quite normal and what
he did he is actually fine I mean Queen
f3 I absolutely did not see that b7 is
hanging so what I was thinking is that I
take takes which is not good but that
was that was my idea and I thought I
would get the knight to d 4 which is 2
and I should be fine
the knight is very strong there but it's
all a bit of a joke because he can take
b7 which I completely did not have on
the radar I was just yeah thinking that
white plays weird anyway and I didn't
really take that into account so takes
it's not good so knight c6 I should play
even though as I mentioned this is
probably going to be a little bit of an
edge forward as I cannot play a form if
I would be somehow able to play Eve or I
would be okay but I cannot do it
so here wide is probably in good shape
it's got this is this square 25 white is
better him the whole the whole operation
with it takes the whole operation it
doesn't make much sense
I cannot gain control over d4 so I
probably here should have retreated to
age 5 by 5 so it took on b7 and you have
to do this takes takes and now he took
on b7 which is probably not good due to
Queen e2 at the end 93 is pointed out by
the engine as being better for what you
know now it's kind of better another
movement
you need to develop and yeah this is
probably probably good for blanket 93 is
only booth
and here you can certainly argue about
things I didn't have much time so h5 was
kind of it's useful to play this move
but d3 it seems is a lot stronger yeah
maybe it actually is a point that I can
get to e5 like if he does that Queen to
e5 is really good a good move
yeah that is really strong and the queen
is good here keeps everything covered
and yeah like he came up to Kiev because
of Queen f5 that takes two pieces okay
this is a stronger option in an age five
but I keep I keep a decent position at
least it's really difficult in such a
technically focused position to play
well if there is no time on the clock so
yeah it was a bit annoying I saw 9f2 I'm
fairly certain he didn't spot that
beforehand it actually doesn't work oops
because he covers d3 in this position
yeah g4 was surprising to me anyway
they're like here I saw this idea but
because this is made I went here there
is 94 action yeah I mean blackest black
is a lot better G form and took we near
4 which is not good oops oh it's this 97
and 9065 happens and then there's a big
blunder I should go g6 right name
hmm I have to keep keep your pawns
finally something something dropped they
are not really well played I should
definitely should probably even avoid c5
here it is the top engine choice no
rupee aid cannot be won probably
probably before yeah yeah or something
else Bishop g4 is really not convincing
if taking on f3 makes no sense and it
doesn't make much sense the way it
turned out
so yeah I should probably go before here
on C takes it takes Bishop g4 those
moves look look better than mine ok
thanks for watching